[Music]  very good man  gone listed five minutes  is a fearful thing to love what death  can touch we're all the minute  yeah I'm took them all off  how has the town fair without any men  around someone's gonna look after things  around here  the town full of ladies it's right  through to the wicked  Frank Griffin's been looking for really  good he's gonna kill anyone that boy  good lots of cares about the good people  of Creed let him walk their streets now  they don't have no streets he finds out  who living here god help you folks  mister we're a lot [ __ ] stronger than  you think we are something I gotta  finish  bad luck we have that in common this  here's the land of the bleedin around  its godless countries  down I'll talk about this like civilized  folks sure come on in  I suggest real first lower our weapons  you  [Music]  you